situé en face de chaumont-sur-loire le
plateau de la gâtine tourangelle abrite
140 hectares de vignoble classé aoc
touraine mêlant autrefois planté sur le
coteau de la loire ce paysage viticole
était visible aujourd'hui une étude
cherche à promouvoir à nouveau ce
territoire elle est menée par le conseil
d'architecturé d'urbanisme et de
l'environnement du loir et cher
on sait que des moines bénédictins se
sont implantés à meylan donc sur une
terre qui leur a été donnée ils ont
défriché on en a les traces et ils ont
planté de la ligne on connaît à peu près
la date ces milieux 11e siècle le
vignoble prendra toute sa valeur quand
les rois de france amateur de vin
s'installeront en val de loire à la fin
du 19e siècle le phylloxéra amènera lui
une transformation radicale du paysage
elle a subi évidemment des grosses
d'évolution la première est la plus
évidente finalement c'est que là on a
effectivement une trame de plantation de
vignes très très orienté avec des fils
de fer et des proportions et des
gabarres xterra ce qui était absolument
pas le cas avant le 19e puisqu'on avait
là-bas des vignes qui était beaucoup
plus ensauvagé en fait donc un paysage
qui est finalement assez récent dans ce
souci de reconnaissance et d'identité le
sérieux et la commune de meylan fédère
vignerons élus et habitants
les vignerons replantent des vignes à
flanc de coteaux et les 600 habitants du
village sont invités à valoriser le
patrimoine communal
nina architecte paysager mène ce projet
il s'agit de réfléchir à la gestion des
espaces verts sur un mode collaboratif
on avait envie de faire des choses ou
faire participer les gens de la commune
voilà en plus avec un budget
relativement modeste parce que bon on
apprenait des grands moyens
donc voilà faire participer les gens que
les gens s'approprient
ce qu'ils construisent et après qu'on
puisse ensemble entretenir le faire
vivre et l'intégrer dans notre village
voilà on travaille à la fois avec les
élus avec les habitants avec les agents
techniques l'idée c'est vraiment de deux
bras c'est à la fois les idées les
compétences de tout le monde se rende
compte aussi que chacun dans une commune
comme mes lancers des choses peut les
apporter au groupe à la fois des idées
des savoir faire
l'idée c'est vraiment pas que nous soit
là en tant que sachant mais plutôt comme
accompagnants ici on est quand même dans
un paysage assez fort avec un village
ancien ou max tapantes vraiment sur le
rebord du relief et qui domine une
vallée qui fait une offre un tout petit
valait 1 mais qui fait une boucle et du
coup on a vraiment cet effet de dominer
un creux et puis on est entouré par la
forêt premier projet la création d'un
jardin à l'entrée du village
nina anime une série d'ateliers pour
tout d'abord confronter les idées
il ya des premières idées une sorte de
brainstorming j'ai plein d'idées sur ce
qui pourrait se faire ici moi j'alimente
je vais chercher des images d'autres
projets qui sont faits ailleurs de
matière de plantation de plein de choses
parce qu'on n'a pas forcément les mots
quand on est habitant lambda pas
habitués au vocabulaire du paysage
l'idée c'est qu'on soit bien sûr qu'on
met les mêmes choses derrière les mêmes
mouton qu'on partage tout un tas de
photos les gens aussi du coup son prix à
ce jeu-là de la collègue d'image donc on
ramenait des magazines ont cherché des
choses sur internet et à partir de ça on
a commencé à dessiner le projet
au final le jardin s'est enrichi d'une
cabane en sol vivant de barrières le
tout fait de matériaux locaux
châtaignier sol piquets de vigne bref un
projet 100% local conçu et réalisé
collectivement
il ya une dynamique qui s'enclenche en
effet où nous les gens se rencontrent se
découvre ce sera des coûts et aux
finalement il se passe beaucoup de
choses entre les temps de rencontre
chose qu avance avec les gens entre eux
aussi les projets collaboratifs
permettent sans doute à moindre coût une
valorisation du patrimoine
mais l'essentiel est sans doute que ces
projets permettent aux habitants de
revisiter leur territoire de revisiter
leur histoire et en agissant de se
réapproprier un paysage commun